how old was charlie when he had his  first kiss  oh  [ __ ] wait i gotta think of that  it says 14 18  14. i know that's i know that's late but  uh charlie just strikes me as a little  bit of a late bloomer not that he  couldn't have been kissed but mm-hmm  good instincts i'm gonna go later not  because he didn't have the opportunity  but because yeah yeah he he he's been  very personal that he would never go for  the the kiss unless he knew it was a  definite which is a hard thing to do  15 or younger so i believe he was 16 on  the cusp of 17.  i i i was tempted to do that i was  tempted to go there and i was like god  that's almost insulting  i believe well don't worry about that  pal because i believe it was actually  17 or i might have even been 18. it was  not until my senior year of high school  my goodness um yeah yeah  i was frustrated about it  [Music]